[Music]
the bad blood between the hosts of
american pickers has been very public
but did you hear about one cast member's
tax scandal keep watching to find out
who the irs had in their sights
for over 10 years television viewers
have been captivated by the wacky and
crazy finds made on the history
channel's hit reality show american
pickers countless items have been
discovered since mike wolfe frank fritz
and danielle colby first made their tv
debuts in 2010 and they continued to
unearth long-lost family artifacts and
heirlooms to this very day sometimes
they have to delve deep into a
stranger's garage to find some hidden
treasure but whether they locate old
vehicles or antique weaponry they always
tend to find something worth a pretty
penny they're masters of sorting through
various memorabilia but they're not the
only ones who enjoy digging up the past
viewers have done the research and
discovered a number of scandals and
secrets such as the controversial firing
of fritz and his reported feud with
wolfe who is still on the show for its
22nd season fritz told the sun we were
never friends in grade school i don't
believe in 10 years he said 5 nice
things to me you know unless he was
cutting somebody else down and we were
both laughing it seems like a lot of
drama for a series that's essentially
about antiquing but there's one
proverbial black eye on the show that
many fans might not know about one of
which could have potentially landed a
cast member behind bars and it's not who
you think anyone who watches american
pickers knows that danielle colby isn't
a person who cares too much about what
others think she's practically covered
from head to toe with tattoos and has
gained fame as a burlesque dancer she
marches to the beat of her own drum and
that's why fans adore her however if
there's one group of people you don't
want to upset it's the irs according to
radar online in 2013 colby reportedly
received a notice from the irs saying
she owed nearly six thousand dollars in
taxes it seemed particularly odd given
that colby is allegedly worth roughly
1.5 million dollars thanks to her
earnings from american pickers the back
taxes are reportedly related to the
reality star's burlesque boutique dubbed
four miles to memphis which received at
least four notices from the feds
documents obtained by radar online
allegedly showed that colby never filed
any returns in june 2014 she was slapped
with a notice of a lien for
5936. in estimated retail taxes for
sales that were made in december 2013.
i'm really greedy with my things my
collection is primarily um
vintage burlesque and sideshow and
circus and striptease costumes there's
currently no documentation online
proving colby paid her taxes but judging
from the fact she's not in federal
prison right now it's a safe bet that
she took care of it however the scandal
might be enough to make some fans worry
about colby's future on american pickers
especially in light of frank fritz's
departure fortunately viewers probably
won't have to say another goodbye
anytime soon colby is still on american
pickers and seems to enjoy continuing to
work with her co-star mike wolfe in fact
she posted a photo of the two of them
together on instagram in august of 2021
where she spoke highly of his character
she wrote thank you for the last decade
of advocacy towards myself and others on
set at mike wolf american picker i'm
proud of how you have handled the last
12 years and look forward to many more
years of rolling around this big blue
marble together she's been thorough in
her efforts to let the world know that
she and mike wolf are still on good
terms during the fritz firestorm colby
uploaded another photo of them together
on instagram writing quote i love
getting to spend time with mike wolfe it
definitely seems like she's on wolf's
good side and american pickers fans no
doubt hope she stays there after the
loss of frankfritz nobody wants to see
colby relegated to the dust bin of
history here's hoping she's paid all her
taxes by now otherwise the next vintage
outfit she might have to pick out for
her boutique could involve black and
white stripes
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebs are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]